We have a voicemail number.
The number is two one nine two, David P. this
voicemail doesn't feel so good to take a listen
to what this person has to say.
Uh, David, you're a liberal hack and Trump
20, 20 Trump's gonna win.
Uh, nobody cares about you and your liberalness.
The reality of the situation is you're just
like Fox news.
We love to criticize just because they love
Trump, but you love Bernie.
So I don't see the difference.
And I think you should be arrested for spreading
baldness information.
And also, if this was Soviet Russia, you'd
have a bullet in your head.
Well, um, now I, I do wonder false misinformation.
Is that a DOE double negative?
Does that mean we're spreading just information?
True information, fun, misinformation would
not be accurate.
If it's false misinformation, maybe it is
good and the person doesn't realize it.
In any case, that's what we are fighting,
right?
So I was there.
Reminder, you're not going to convince that
person to vote for anybody other than Trump,
so don't bother.
Don't waste your time on it.
And these, I play these voicemails for you,
number one, just to let you know, but the
level of vitriol that exists out there, but
number two, because these are illustrations
that we can't win, we, it's not a viable strategy
to say, let's all go out and convince people
like that, dude, not to vote for Trump.
It's not going to happen.
The focus needs to be, get out the vote, prevent
voter suppression, prevent a toxic, destructive
primary that will actually do damage to the
opportunity to remove Donald Trump.
That is the focus.
Find the half of the country that doesn't
vote and talk to the people who agree with
us and make sure that they go out and vote
because a conversation with that guy is a
dead end.
You might as well run a motorcycle directly
into a brick wall.
You're not going to get anything accomplished.
The focus has to be a different one.
We have a great bonus feel for you today.
We will talk about DNC members who are discussing
possible rule changes at the convention to
potentially deny Bernie Sanders the nomination
if it were to come to it.
Secondly, even insured adults who have health
insurance are increasingly going to primary
care less and less often because of the out-of-pocket
costs.
These are folks with insurance.
We will talk about that.
We will also talk about the news shocking
in the media world.
That right wing radio host, rush Limbaugh
says he has advanced lung cancer.
Immediately, we'll be missing a lot of his
show undergoing treatment.
We will discuss that and much more on today's
bonus show.
Get access instantly by becoming a member@joinpacman.com
or by becoming a [inaudible]
patron@thefivedollarorgreaterlevelatpatriondotcomslashdavidthedavidpakmanshowatdavidpakman.com
[inaudible].